it'll be a fun election we'll talk about
it i will have fun
we're gonna have fun with it here
everybody else is gonna get mad they're
gonna tell you to vote i don't care who
you vote for
i don't care i don't care if you don't
vote i don't care
imagine caring imagine
care imagine being at lunch and
caring you're not gonna take my life
that's the way i feel yeah you're not
going to ruin my life
i'm on twitter i'm on all these things
you're not gonna ruin my life
i don't care what you do i am a being
that's having a wild experience on the
planet
i wish that realization for you i wish
that realization for all of you out
there
that you're not subject to all this [ __ ]
it's not
real but uh quarantine you know we went
to new york to like you got a quarantine
and you got to fill out you know i put
the cat in the hat i folded it up you
fold it up like origami you put it
they have these things in a suggestion
box you put your gives a [ __ ]
cares this state's too goddamn sloppy to
be fascist everyone's too
fat they can't put the
they can't find their gun it's stuck in
a roll of fat
it's it's gonna get bad but it won't get
bad for a while
it's pretty bad now but i mean real bad
i mean like can't leave your house bad
so enjoy the time you have left these
laws and [ __ ] you think you're it's it's
not there's no teeth too many of them
some of them there is teeth too and some
of them are going to be worse and if you
can stop
by all means if you can stop people if
you can get us all of our freedoms back
i'm
i'd like that i'd love that
but up until that point i'm not going to
ruin
and waste i don't know how many hours
days minutes i have on this earth
none of us do how many tweets do you
want to read
about amy coney barrett how many
how many tweets do you want to read
about joe biden's crack addict son
in the ukraine who's [ __ ] stealing
money and smoking crack
and by the way good for him he had
fun is he is he alive still or no yeah
oh
hunter yeah yeah he's alive he's the the
one that didn't smoke crack died
ain't that the way
i just go off after i don't know how
much time
do you have any water is that water what
happens that's okay we don't i don't
need that i don't need it we're almost
done here
i just yell so much and then sometimes i
don't
i get frustrated you know my aunt sent
me a pumpkin with an i voted sticker on
it's like will you grow up
i love her but come on you've only got a
few more
listen we all we might not have that
many years of going
outside left we might not have that many
years
of going outside left and you people are
talking about amy coney barrett
go swim while you can go hike while you
can go fish while you can
go [ __ ] while you can go enjoy the world
while you can go have dinner with
friends while you can i'm telling them
not
i'm not even kidding it's not a joke
we're in a whole heap of [ __ ]
and if you don't want to enjoy whatever
time any of us have left on this [ __ ]
planet
we could all get this disease tomorrow
and drop dead they could send another 5g
reboot of this disease i'm not being a
conspiracy wacko i'm saying who the [ __ ]
knows what's the next
corona right corona what is it covered
19 what
clover 20 might be the one right that
might be the one where you get it and
you fall down
in the middle of the [ __ ] street so
if you're
driven to be an activist god bless you
if you're
faking it which you are
relax experience real friendship
make a real friend you know
like dan who i [ __ ] go on the road
with who's [ __ ] great dude who comes
on the patreon
and everybody on the patreon loses their
mind because i'm not yelling for a whole
hour
and i let a person make a human point
for a minute and then maybe i have a
friend and we're
we're out there under you know we're
trying to have a nice conversation about
it everybody's like
maybe this guy should kill himself
i yell every episode one
at one episode i take a minute to say
hey this is what's been going on and
and you're like hey
where's the unfocused rage
here it is you got it here
but make a friend go through me and this
kid are doing stand-up comedy in a weird
[ __ ] world traveling all over the
place
having a lot of fun laughing our asses
off enjoying our [ __ ] lives
we don't know when they're ending we
don't know
but we're gonna [ __ ] laugh our asses
off until they do
i wish that for a lot of people that
literally
get in touch with something spiritual
whatever
for me it's making people laugh for you
i don't know what it is i don't know
what and i don't tell people it's not
the gary vee
experience i'm not going to tell you
what to do i'm not going to tell you
that
you know it's spiritual start a vape
company or a hoodie
i don't know but if it is it is
but you're ruining and wasting your
[ __ ] lives every [ __ ] day you're
starting you're fighting you're fighting
with people in your family that you
you you might like if you didn't hate
each other for no reason
because you have different opinions on
nancy pelosi a woman who you've never
met
either side of your family has never met
her uh whether you love her hate her she
doesn't give a [ __ ] about you
during the remember she was giving a
tour at [ __ ] gelato
in her [ __ ] freezer and she lives in
san francisco
that's basic [ __ ] [ __ ] okay that's a
foodie city
and you're the [ __ ] speaker of the
[ __ ] house why don't you get some
real [ __ ] ice cream in there okay
you 119 year old remember when a bird
flew into her georgetown
[ __ ] townhouse and she had to chase
it around that bird was trying to drag
her back to the dimension she belongs in
and somehow she fought off that burden
she's here showing us [ __ ] salted
caramel gelato
while the world [ __ ] burns and you
guys are fighting about her as if she
gives a [ __ ]
it's the wicked witch of the west is
that what they did in oz well
actually actually the flying monkeys are
really happy the benefit pack
what enough
with this children have some fun
when's the last time you people had any
goddamn fun
have a little bit of fun you know when i
used to be able to go to my my mother's
mental institution i would have fun
i would visit all the other mental
patients and talk to them
and then i started to realize that they
were actually right about the world
they'd be like everyone's trying to kill
you out there and i um
okay and then more recently i've gone
go on
you know i mean life life is not
supposed to be
an endless procession of of and yes
hey crap like this little guy that i
have with me danny goes he always goes
he goes
i want a great quality of life he says
it all the time and uh this is what the
kids they go
i want a really good quality of life and
he's right but also
shut the [ __ ] up don't vocalize those
thoughts just shut up create the quality
of life
but that's what i would tell everybody
out there go out there
and get in some type of situation
universe world where you feel you're
being [ __ ]
you're excited about something because
dude people [ __ ] die [ __ ] ends i hope
this isn't my last episode by the way
this is
this is very like this is very strange
right it's very odd like can i just die
and this
first of all if it is it's brilliant but
i just don't want
i don't want i want to stay here because
i just started
just started doing well after 11 years i
don't want to be too cryptic
but i will tell you this you got to
enjoy whatever you're [ __ ] doing you
got to enjoy the time you have you
and don't invest yourself and [ __ ]
unless you really are prepared to do the
work of investing yourself in it you
know